i went to uh dave and buster's this
weekend yeah yeah how was that that's
what i did i'm not gonna lie i was
a little jelly dude it reminded me of
being on tour honestly i mean the the
experience of dave and buster's this is
not even a brand deal it's it's
literally therapeutic they don't tell
you that about life i was like go to
therapy
talk to someone
nah
go to dnb go to dmb yeah so
how many tickets you walk away with this
time dude 11 000. over no 15 000
probably out of here
i mean like we [ __ ]
blew a bag there it was just ridiculous
it was
like just the most egregious wasteful
thing ever i walked in
and she was like thousand dollars with
the tokens yeah she said how many how
many cards you want and i was with seven
people and so i looked around i was like
well seven cards and i'll just do the
top one which is 100 bucks and she's
like 100 bucks on each card and i was
like yeah and she was like
i mean and i was like what how how many
games is that going to get us i mean
she's like i mean you're going to be
here for like two three hours so i was
like oh
plan on being here all day
i'm not going home
and so
we did that like she she was like are
you sure like three times like it's
seven hundred dollars and i was like and
i'll say it it was marcus's birthday so
i was like yes yes so i was like i want
to treat this and yeah i want to do this
it's dave and buster's supposed to have
fun i don't want to like run out of
tickets and then i have to like
sheepishly walk back there can i refill
my car because she would have shamed you
then too yeah exactly oh did you did you
lose on deal or no deal already
are you another 20 right now
wow buddy you're only here 30 minutes
okay
no it's cool it's cool just most people
tend to make that last hour i mean the
saddest part was that we spent almost
all of it on that [ __ ] coin game
rolling the coin down the not that one
it already has coins in it so you just
swipe your card and then you just jam
the button and the coins come out
oh and it's like it pushes the coins
forward it's got the little shelf yeah
it's like a two layer one so the coins
drop and they push those coins off but
it was a star trek one
of course of course
everyone when you said that was like ah
that one the star trek one well everyone
had a lot of judgment until you said
that seven hundred dollars cody that's a
[ __ ] wait the star trek machine yeah
yeah yeah yeah
well let me explain this
why it was so there's a guy named spock
he does this hand thing and chewbacca
star wars yeah he's trying to get
another that's a different machine yeah
yeah so the more coins you put in it
pushes the coins off those get you
points right then there's like these
dave and buster's like chips that gets
you tickets oh i'm getting excited and
then hearing that there's star wars like
collector's cards in there
and if you complete a full set of all
eight people
then you get 2500
tickets but then if you complete the set
of the holographic ones
you get five thousand tickets don't even
get me started so we're all just like
dude there's like five guys the girls
are standing there like what are you
guys doing
and it's five guys just scanning this
thing over and we have one person
scanning the card and one person's just
jamming the button since coins are just
falling tickets falling
we had we completed like eight sets of
these [ __ ] cards
and we didn't even trade the tickets in
for anything you just walked out with it
wow i respect that and just we had all
these star wars cards yeah
it was awesome star trek sorry
i know i would i would probably just
ball up all those tickets yeah and
maybe like get them laminated or get
some artists to like
you know
like memorialize them yeah and just put
that in the middle of the house just a
big ass bundle of [ __ ] d b tickets
oh who made this
me and my friends damien hurst
you know the guy did clb yeah
the cover
yeah he's got nothing to do with this
this is our hard work
me and the boys the thing is they don't
print out the tickets they go on the
card oh but we just had like
infinite of these like d and b
like
chips that you get from the thing and a
bunch of collectors star trek cards oh
what it was sick dave and buster's what
you don't need to be eco-friendly you're
literally just a [ __ ] place like
burn the trees down to make the tickets
earth's going on fire anyway who cares
that's true
the whole building would have been going
crazy like do you see those guys on the
star trek machine
jackpot yeah like at a casino when
someone's hit yeah you would have
emptied out emptied it out someone would
have had to walk over put a whole roll
in
you guys would just stood there like
five fries like put the [ __ ] rolls
yeah yeah we did break the machine like
five times
i had to come over and un gen every
every single time we go over hey it's
jammed again like
how do you keep no one has played this
for this long it's a boring game you're
not supposed to play it like it's the
most obscure area of dave and buster's
because they don't want people to play
it by the fire exit yeah pretty much
yeah
and then so and then sam's on reddit of
course he's on the dave and buster's
subreddit of course trying to figure out
what the most efficient game is to get
the most amount of tickets i can't
believe is a dave and buster's subreddit
man dude the saddest part was he told me
this he uh he said he was on the reddit
and this guy was like hey the most
efficient game is the football game and
this is the way that you beat it and get
the most amount of tickets out of it
it's like giant explanation and someone
was like how how do you know this and
he's like
brother i've been going to dave and
buster's for a long time like i've
figured this [ __ ] out and then that was
10 years ago that he posted that on the
subreddit and so he goes to his profile
and his most recent post was in the dave
and buster's subreddit from 10 minutes
ago
this man has been
like like on there a power user of this
subreddit for 10 years
and even before that he had already
mastered dave and busters
so just
two decades this guy has been just
a creature at at uh dave and buster you
know when he walks in that building he
feels like a a machine like a killer
like nos to the bartender what's up yeah
jerry
samantha good to see you guys they're
like [ __ ] this guy's so sad
good to see you guys you know what it'll
be same thing every time 700 tickets
please
he's got like a holster for his card
like almost like a
like a hip holster like a 90s like
failed
uh like hip wallet it's like plastic
with like
plastic switches on it so he just like
he just like
like
he just
rolls his hand and smoothly pushes his
thumb on the dmv
labeled clip he's like and it pops out
he's like
holds like a [ __ ] pokemon card
you know what it'll be samantha and then
some some some just
you know unsuspecting couples in land
they're like oh
it's kind of cool you know what's cooler
what am i walk out of here with that air
fryer right there
i don't even need it i have seven at
home
and they're like 50 000 isn't that like
700
it's not about the money it's about
beating this place neither dave or
buster are busting this guy you think
like he's got
some like fast sunglasses with the strap
in the back yes or the regular glasses
no i think fast okay fast glass i think
fast and a hat with the brim like way
too uh curled up yeah curled up maybe he
used to be a college athlete or
something like that and he thinks that
this is like an equivalent of that he
just wears one cleat yeah yeah yeah one
cleat one regular shoot with jeans boot
cut jeans
[Laughter]
i use this one for leverage
it digs in real nice of the carpet and
then i can just swing it
[Laughter]
let me show you something let me show
you something walks them over because in
the soccer game where there's like the
[ __ ]
person in front of it like panning left
and right talking about the football
game there's someone where you can throw
footballs that's the one that's how did
i just confuse football for soccer wow
too much love island right yes sir jeez
yeah no this is like the nfl one
there's like little holes in the wall
and you throw them still and then
there's still one and there's like
defenders that pop up from the side oh
you get those
[Laughter]
he's like sitting there he's like he's
like watch this watch this three two pop
out not gonna get me
yeah
my offense is too good
he's like
yeah this one you got to run a shotgun
just run straight into the machine this
[ __ ] barrels through all that and
then just that couple is like just
holding their [ __ ] you know lime
green
margarita it looks like it just looks
radioactive they're like that's really
cool
let's let's leave honey
that guy's just
in his own world
bam bam bam bam gary get the [ __ ] out of
the machine
oh no you can't gary's
digs his cleat into the thing he can't
get me out
grabs him by the shirt
get the [ __ ] out of here
[Laughter]
[ __ ] airfryer
you